Oil sands operations contribute significant carbon emissions in Canada. So the six largest companies have teamed up to make strides on the path to NetZero. Investing in technology and innovation. Already cut emissions an average 22% per barrel. Working with governments to create and protect jobs. Developing one of the world's largest carbon capture and storage facilities. Our NetZero plan is in motion and we're making progress on multiple pathways. See our plan in action at pathwaysalliance.ca
加拿大油砂开采产生了大量的碳排放，因此六家最大的公司联手在通往净零排放的道路上大步迈进。我们投资于技术和创新，每桶碳排放量已经平均减少了22%，并与政府合作创造和保护就业岗位，开发全球最大的碳捕集与封存设施之一。我们的净零计划正在实施中，我们正通过多种途径取得进展。请访问pathwaysalliance.ca查看我们的实际计划。
Music Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. Today's episode deals with a crime committed against a child. It won't be suitable for all listeners. Music 11 year old Shauna Howe looked forward to Halloween every year.
音乐 我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候觉得需要支持，请联系当地的危机中心。有关保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您应用程序上或我们网站上的本集节目说明。今天的节目涉及针对儿童的犯罪，并不适合所有听众。音乐 11岁的肖娜·豪每年都盼望着万圣节的到来。
She was enthralled by the spooky decorations, scary stories and costume parties that started a full week before the holiday. Culminating in the most exciting event of all. Trick or treating on the night of October 31st. In late October 1992, like every other town in America, Oil City in northern Pennsylvania's Venango County was preparing for Halloween. Oil City sits on a bend of the Allegheny River at the mouth of Oil Creek, about an hour and a half north of Pittsburgh. As its name suggests, the city was founded on the nearby oil fields and the wealth that came with the oil boom, and later, the steel industry. At its peak, the town boasted a population of 22,000 residents, with job seekers attracted by the thriving employment prospects.
她深深迷恋那些在假期前整整一周就开始出现的幽灵装饰、恐怖故事和化妆派对，并在最令人兴奋的活动中达到高潮——10月31日晚上的不给糖就捣蛋。1992年10月下旬，就像美国其他所有城镇一样，位于宾夕法尼亚州北部韦南戈县的石油城正在筹备万圣节。石油城坐落在阿勒泰尼河的一处河曲上，位于油溪口，在匹兹堡以北大约一个半小时车程的地方。顾名思义，这座城市建立在附近的油田以及石油繁荣带来的财富之上，后来又发展了钢铁工业。在其鼎盛时期，该镇曾拥有22000名居民，繁荣的就业前景吸引了许多求职者。
But after being hit hard by the collapse of the steel industry, Oil City became the poster child for the Rust Belt. Locals calculated the decline in Oil City's population by reference to each closing gas station. The town offered a cheap cost of living, but gainful employment became scarce. As factories moved and entire industries were shifted offshore, jobs and people followed. The town had little to offer young people, many of whom dropped out of school and became trapped in a cycle of poverty. Those who grew up and moved away often never came back. On the morning of Tuesday, October 27, 1992, Lucy listened as her young daughter Shauna chatted about her upcoming plans as she prepared herself for the day ahead. That afternoon, Shauna intended to go straight from Seventh Street School to the local nursing home where she would join her Girl Scout troop in singing to the elderly residents.
但在遭受钢铁工业崩溃的沉重打击之后，石油城成了铁锈地带的典型代表。当地人通过参考每一家倒闭的加油站来计算石油城人口的下降。该镇的生活成本很低，但谋生工作却变得稀缺。随着工厂搬迁和整个产业转移到海外，工作岗位和人口也随之流失。这个小镇几乎没有什么能提供给年轻人的，其中许多人辍学并陷入了贫困的恶性循环。那些长大后搬走的人往往再也没有回来。1992年10月27日星期二早晨，露西听着她的小女儿肖娜在为新的一天做准备时，叽叽喳喳地聊着她接下来24小时的计划。那天下午，肖娜打算直接从第七街学校去当地的疗养院，加入她的女童军小分队，为老年居民唱歌。
Shauna sang in the children's choir at church so she was looking forward to performing for the senior citizens, but she was most excited about what was to follow. After the performance, she planned to head to the first free Methodist Church for a Halloween party. The Howe family didn't have the money for Shauna to spend on an elaborate fancy dress costume, so the 11-year-old improvised. She decided to dress up as a gymnast, wearing a turquoise bodysuit with black stripes, tights, sneakers and soft satin-y gloves that stretched up above her elbows. As she would not have time to come home after school to change outfits, she wore the leotard underneath her regular clothes. The 400 block of West First Street where Shauna lived with her mother, stepfather, 12-year-old brother and 5-year-old sister was in one of the poorer areas of the town. Nevertheless, it was regarded as safe by residents who rarely worried about locking their houses or cars, and Lucy had no hesitation in letting her daughter make her own way to and from school. Navigating the familiar streets at night time was different as Shauna was afraid of the dark, so her mother would arrange to have someone pick her up after the Halloween party that evening.
肖娜在教堂的儿童唱诗班唱歌，所以她很期盼为老年人表演，但她最兴奋的是接下来的活动。表演结束后，她计划前往第一自由卫理公会教堂参加万圣节派对。豪家没有多余的钱让肖娜买一件精美的化装服，于是这个11岁的女孩即兴发挥。她决定扮成一名体操运动员，穿着一件带有黑色条纹的蓝绿色紧身连衣裤、紧身裤、运动鞋以及长到手肘以上的柔软缎面手套。由于放学后没有时间回家换衣服，她把紧身衣穿在了便服里面。肖娜和她的母亲、继父、12岁的哥哥以及5岁的妹妹居住在西第一街400号，这里是该镇较贫困的地区之一。尽管如此，居民们仍认为这里很安全，他们很少担心锁房子或锁车，露西也毫不犹豫地让女儿自己上下学。在夜间穿过熟悉的街道则有所不同，因为肖娜怕黑，所以她的母亲会安排人在那天晚上的万圣节派对结束后接她。
Later that night, Lucy was working her regular shift at a pizza shop in the nearby town of Franklin when she called home to check in on her family. Her de facto partner, John Brown, told her Shauna still hadn't arrived home from the Halloween party. Lucy realized she had forgotten to arrange someone to pick her daughter up from the event, but was reassured by the fact the church was only a short half-mile walk away from their block along familiar streets that Shauna had travelled many times before. By 8.30pm, long past the time she was expected to return, Shauna still hadn't arrived home. John didn't have the phone numbers of the friends she may have walked home with, and unable to contact anyone, he jumped into his car and drove the route she would have most likely taken, expecting to spot her along the way. Although there were a couple of different routes from the church to their home, John was certain Shauna would have stuck to the main roads. Failing to find her walking the streets, John progressed to the first free Methodist church where the Halloween celebrations were taking place, only to realize the party had long since finished and all the other Girl Scouts had already gone home. Although Shauna could be headstrong, she was otherwise obedient and not the type to take off to a friend's house without letting someone know, so John continued to scout the nearby streets expecting to find her.
那天晚些时候，露西正在附近富兰克林镇的一家比萨店值常规班，她打电话回家了解家里情况。她的事实婚姻伴侣约翰·布朗告诉她，肖娜还没从万圣节派对回家。露西意识到她忘了一劳永逸地安排人去活动现场接女儿，但转念一想，教堂距离他们所在的街区只有短短半英里路程，而且都是肖娜以前走过很多次的熟悉街道，这让她感到安心。到了晚上8点30分，早过了她预期返回的时间，肖娜依然没有到家。约翰没有那些可能和她一起走回家的朋友的电话号码，在无法联系到任何人的情况下，他跳上车，沿着她最可能走的路线开去，希望能一路上找到她。虽然从教堂到他们家有几条不同的路线，但约翰确信肖娜一定会走主路。在街上没有找到她后，约翰继续前往万圣节庆祝活动举办的第一自由卫理公会教堂，结果却发现派对早已结束，其他女童军也都已经回家了。虽然肖娜有时有些顽固，但她平时很听话，不是那种不打招呼就跑到朋友家去的人，于是约翰继续在附近的街道上搜寻，希望能找到她。
After exhausting the search of the neighborhood, John returned home to find Shauna hadn't returned during his absence. At 9.30pm, Lucy found home again and suggested her daughter maybe at the home of her former husband, Shauna's father, Robert Howe. Although the ex-husband and wife had a tumultuous relationship, their four children remained close to their father, with Shauna's nine-year-old sister living with him in a neighboring town. Lucy contacted Robert, who swore Shauna was not with him. Unsure whether to believe him, Lucy finished her shift and rushed home. Upon her arrival, she called the parents of Shauna's best friend, Joyeel, who was a member of the same Girl Scout group. Joyeel confirmed Shauna had been at the church Halloween party and explained that when it ended, the two girls set off together in the same direction at around 8pm. When they reached the point where they needed to part ways to head towards their respective homes, Shauna expressed that she was afraid to walk in the dark and asked Joyeel to walk with her.
在精疲力竭地搜寻了整个社区后，约翰回到家，发现肖娜在他离开期间并没有回来。晚上9点30分，露西再次打通了家里的电话，并建议女儿可能在前夫、肖娜的生父罗伯特·豪的家里。尽管这位前夫和前妻的关系曾经很动荡，但他们的四个孩子和父亲依然很亲近，肖娜9岁的妹妹就和父亲住在邻近的一个镇上。露西联系了罗伯特，罗伯特发誓肖娜并不在他那里。由于不确定是否该相信他，露西结束了当天的班次，急忙赶回家中。一到家，她就打电话给肖娜最好的朋友乔伊尔的父母，乔伊尔和肖娜属于同一个女童军小组。乔伊尔证实肖娜确实去过教堂的万圣节派对，并解释说派对结束后，两个女孩在大约晚上8点时朝着同一个方向一起出发了。当她们走到需要分头走向各自家里的路口时，肖娜表示她害怕在黑暗中行走，并请求乔伊尔陪她一起走。
Joyeel suggested that they instead go back to her place and from there her father would walk Shauna safely home. Shauna declined the offer, saying, no, that's alright, before heading off alone on the ten-minute walk towards her home. By 10pm, Shauna had not been heard from for two hours, prompting her mother to call the police and report the 11-year-old as missing. At the time of Lucy's call, oil city police were in the midst of investigating an odd occurrence that had been reported earlier that night. At 8.06pm, local resident Dan Paydon had been walking along Reed Street, a leafy suburban neighbourhood lined with residential houses, when he sighted a young girl dressed in a top-and-shorts walking alone down West 1st Street. She was approaching the Reed Street intersection in front of a medical centre across the road from the Presbyterian Church. A tall, thin, scruffy-looking man wearing an army jacket and baseball cap was walking in the same direction on the opposite sidewalk, smoking a cigarette.
乔伊尔建议她们改道去她家，然后由她父亲送肖娜安全回家。肖娜拒绝了这个提议，说了声“不，没关系”，然后独自一人踏上了回家的十分钟路程。到了晚上10点，已经有两个小时没有肖娜的音讯了，这促使她的母亲打电话报警，将这名11岁的女孩报告为失踪人口。在露西打电话时，石油城警方正在调查当晚早些时候报告的一起诡异事件。晚上8点06分，当地居民丹·佩登正沿着里德街步行，这是一条绿树成荫、两旁都是住宅的郊区街道，这时他看到一个穿着上衣和短裤的小女孩独自沿着西第一街走着。她正走近马路对面长老会教堂前方的医疗中心前的里德街十字路口。一个身材高大、消瘦、衣着邋遢、戴着军用夹克和棒球帽的男子正走在对面的行人道上，抽着烟。
Dan observed the man cross to the other side of the road before appearing to scoop the girl up and run around the corner. Seconds later, he heard a muffled scream. Dan ran towards the intersection and witnessed a small, boxy, dark red sedan vehicle speed away. It looked to be an Oldsmobile with Pennsylvania State license plates, but it moved too quickly for Dan to catch the plate number. Although he hadn't seen the man put the girl in the car, both he and the girl were now gone. Dan immediately began banging on the doors of nearby houses until a woman answered before frantically telling her, I've just seen a little girl kidnapped and I need to call the police. As no one had reported a missing child at the time, police were unsure whether Dan had witnessed an abduction or simply a father picking up his errant child. But the phone call from Lucy later that night confirmed the worst-case scenario.
丹看到那名男子穿过马路，随后似乎把女孩抱起来，绕过了街角。几秒钟后，他听到了一声闷闷不乐的尖叫。丹向十字路口跑去，亲眼看到一辆小型的、方头方脑的深红色轿车加速驶离。这看起来像是一辆挂有宾夕法尼亚州车牌的奥兹莫比尔汽车，但它开得太快，丹没能看清车牌号。虽然他没有看到男子把女孩塞进车里，但现在他和女孩都已经不见了。丹立即开始敲击附近房屋的房门，直到一位妇女应门，他惊慌失措地告诉她：“我刚刚看到一个小女孩被绑架了，我需要报警。”由于当时没有人报告儿童失踪，警方不确定丹目睹的是一起绑架案，还是仅仅是一位父亲在接他调皮的孩子。但露西当晚晚些时候打来的电话证实了最糟糕的情况。
The Reed and West First intersection was a couple of blocks from Shawna House home, and if Dan Payden's recollections were factual, it appeared the child had been snatched whilst walking home. The oil city police set up a roadblock on the road leading out of town and informed every police station within a 99-mile radius of the situation unfolding. Local officers came to the area by patrol car and on foot and paid a visit to the home of Shawna's father, Robert Howe, to confirm the girl wasn't there. Seeing the unusual police activity around the typically quiet streets, locals soon joined in on the search for Shawna. By late morning, word had spread throughout town that Shawna Howe was missing, prompting hundreds of volunteers to comb the streets into nearby forests looking for any signs of the child. With police considering the possibility that Shawna may have been kidnapped for ransom, her mother remained housebound in case the perpetrators made contact, helplessly pacing back and forth awaiting any news. State troopers door-knocked along the route it was believed Shawna had taken the night prior, asking residents whether they had seen anything suspicious. But other than Dan Payden, no one had. Detectives were not convinced Dan was a particularly reliable witness, as there were elements of his story that didn't quite add up.
里德街和西第一街的十字路口距离肖娜家只有几个街区，如果丹·佩登的回忆属实，这个孩子显然是在回家路上被强行掳走的。石油城警方在通往城外的道路上设置了路障，并将这一突发情况通知了方圆99英里内的每一个警察局。当地警员乘巡逻车和步行赶到该地区，并造访了肖娜生父罗伯特·豪的家，以确认女孩不在那里。看到这个通常安静的街道周围出现罕见的警察活动，当地人很快也加入了寻找肖娜的行列。到了深夜，肖娜·hu失踪的消息已经在镇上传开，这促使数百名志愿者梳理街道，并进入附近的森林寻找孩子的任何踪迹。由于警方考虑到肖娜可能被绑架索要赎金的可能性，她的母亲一直呆在家中，以防绑匪联系她，她无助地来回踱步，等待着任何消息。州骑警沿着据信肖娜前一天晚上的路线逐户敲门，询问居民是否看到任何可疑情况。但除了丹·佩登之外，没有人看到过。侦探们并不确信丹是一个特别可靠的证人，因为他的故事中有些部分不太对劲。
If he had seen the girl being taken, the question remained as to why he didn't try to intervene or stop the perpetrator from getting away. A suspicious eye was cast on Dan himself, who was questioned several times by police, but remained steadfast about his version of events. The next day, October 29, a search party led by Shawna's uncle Keith decided to take their efforts into the wooded area bordering Oil City. They headed in a southerly direction along Big Egypt Road towards Cranberry Township, before moving into the 60 acres of woodland of Waltonian Park. They then ventured seven and a half miles south of Oil City to the Rockland Township, heading out to Coulter's Hole, a secluded swimming and camping spot popular with fishermen, hunters and picnickers. At night, the area was frequented by teens participating in underage drinking and drug-taking, while the Oil City chapter of the Kingsman Biker Club was also known to use the location as a party spot. Upon reaching Coulter's Hole, Keith and his search party split up to cover more ground, but it wasn't long before he was being called to check something out. A searcher was crossing a long deserted railway bridge that overlooked the forest when he peered over the rail and spotted a flash of colour that looked like a piece of children's clothing.
如果他真的看到女孩被带走，问题仍然在于为什么他没有试图干预或阻止作案者逃跑。警方对丹本人产生了怀疑，并对他进行了多次盘问，但他对自己的事件版本始终坚定不移。第二天，即10月29日，由肖娜的叔叔基思带队的一支搜寻队决定将搜寻范围扩大到石油城边缘的林区。他们沿着大埃及路向南朝克兰berry镇方向前进，然后进入华尔特尼安公园60英亩的林地。接着，他们向南探险，来到距离石油城七英里半的罗克兰镇，前往库尔特深潭，这是一个深受渔民、猎人和野餐者欢迎的偏僻游泳和露营地。到了晚上，这个地区经常有参与未成年饮酒和吸毒的青少年光顾，而石油城国王人摩托车俱乐部的分会也众所周知将此地用作派对场所。一到达库尔特深潭，基思和他的搜寻队员便分散开来以扩大搜寻范围，但没过多久，他就被叫去查看情况。一名搜寻队员正走过一座俯瞰森林的荒废已久的铁路桥，他探头向栏杆外望去，瞥见了一抹彩色的闪光，看起来像是一件儿童衣物。
When Keith joined the man on the bridge, he felt sick. The item that lay far below matched the description of the turquoise bodysuit Shauna had worn as part of her gymnast costume on the night she vanished. Police brought Shauna's stepfather, John Brown, to the scene, who confirmed the item of clothing belonged to his stepdaughter. A large-scale police search of the area commenced with assistance from a mass of volunteers, including members of Shauna's extended family. Despite their efforts, nothing else of significance was found. Flyers featuring Shauna's picture were distributed throughout town, describing her as five foot tall, weighing 78 pounds with straight brown hair, blue eyes, one scar behind her right ear, and another in the middle of her forehead. Her mother Lucy appeared on local television pleading for the safe release of her daughter, while her stepfather fronted the press, saying, It's hard holding on, but you've got to do it, because that's the only thing we have. At approximately 9am the following morning of October 30, just 500 yards from the location where Shauna's bodysuit was found, a man who had been camping at Coulter's Hole was walking in a desolate area underneath an abandoned Trestle railway bridge. As he navigated alongside the dry, rocky creekbed, he saw the body of a young girl lying face down between a rock and a log. She was dressed in shorts, knee-high socks, and a short-sleeved shirt which was inside out and back to front.
当基思和那名男子汇合在桥上时，他感到胃里一阵翻江倒海。下方远处的那个物品与肖娜失踪当晚作为体操运动员服装一部分所穿的那件蓝绿色紧身连衣裤的描述完全相符。警方将肖娜的继父约翰·布朗带到现场，他确认这件衣物属于他的继女。在大量志愿者（包括肖娜的家属）的协助下，警方对该地区展开了大规模搜寻。尽管他们作出了努力，但没有发现其他有价值的东西。印有肖娜照片的传单在全镇分发，描述她身高五英尺，体重78磅，留着直直的棕色头发，蓝眼睛，右耳后有一道疤痕，额头中间还有另一道疤痕。她的母亲露西出现在当地电视台，恳求安全释放她的女儿，而她的继父则面对媒体说：“坚持下去很难，但你必须这样做，因为这是我们仅有的东西。”在第二天（10月30日）上午9点左右，距离发现肖娜紧身衣的位置仅500码远的地方，一名在库尔特深潭露营的男子正在一座废弃的桁架铁路桥下方荒凉的区域散步。当他在干燥多石的小溪河床旁行走时，他看到一个年轻女孩的尸体面朝下躺在一块岩石和一根圆木之间。她穿着短裤、过膝袜以及一件里外穿反、前后穿反的短袖衬衫。
She wasn't wearing any shoes, and her feet were partially submerged in a shallow stream. Shauna's uncles Keith and Claire were on hand to identify the body, confirming their niece had been found. Police immediately cordoned off the area and initiated a search, discovering a lollipop wrapper and an abandoned campsite near where Shauna was found. They found Shauna's sneakers on the Trestle bridge, high above the dry creekbed. Police believed the child had either been running along the bridge when she tripped and fell the 33-foot drop into the creekbed below, or that someone had staged her shoes to suggest this outcome. Police were confounded as they had searched the area the day before and were positive they would have found Shauna's body if it was there at the time. When given the devastating news that her daughter had been found, Lucy was inconsolable. She later confirmed that the shirt and shorts Shauna was wearing were indeed her daughters, but she didn't know who the socks belonged to.
她没有穿鞋，双脚部分浸没在浅浅的溪流中。肖娜的叔叔基思和克莱尔在现场辨认了尸体，确认他们的侄女已经被找到。警方立即封锁了该区域并展开搜寻，在发现肖娜的地点附近找到了一个棒棒糖包装纸和一个废弃的营地。他们在高高的、位于干涸溪床之上的桁架桥上找到了肖娜的运动鞋。警方认为，这个孩子要么是在桥上奔跑时不小心绊倒，坠落到33英尺以下的溪床中，要么是有人伪造了她的鞋子以制造这种假象。警方感到十分困惑，因为他们前一天刚刚搜查过该区域，并确信如果当时尸体在那里的话，他们一定能找到。当听到女儿被找到的毁灭性消息时，露西悲痛欲绝。她后来证实，肖娜穿着的衬衫和短裤确实是她女儿的，但她不知道那些袜子属于谁。
As Shauna's disappearance shifted into a homicide investigation, Oil City authorities announced that Halloween was officially cancelled, with police urging all parents to keep a watchful eye on their children and not let them out alone after dark. On October 31, instead of celebrating Halloween, hundreds of Oil City townsfolk participated in a silent candlelit procession to honour Shauna's memory. They prayed and comforted one another as they walked what they believed to be Shauna's final route, starting from the First Free Methodist Church to the Reed and West First Street intersection, less than two blocks from her home. Meanwhile, results of forensic testing revealed Shauna's death had been caused by severe blunt force trauma to the head and chest, caused by the fall from the trestle bridge to the ground below. She was alive at the time of descent and may have survived for up to 30 minutes before succumbing to her injuries. There was evidence of sexual assault, with stains present on her body suit testing positive for seminal fluid. Her knees were scuffed and scraped from a rough flooring surface, with investigators presuming it arose from the area she was held captive. In the previous 15 months, there had been three homicides in Oil City, and in each case, the victim was killed by a member of their family.
随着肖娜的失踪案转为凶杀案调查，石油城当局宣布万圣节正式取消，警方敦促所有父母密切关注自己的孩子，切勿让他们在天黑后独自外出。10月31日，石油城的数百名镇民没有庆祝万圣节，而是参加了一场无声的烛光游行，以纪念肖娜。他们祈祷并互相安慰，走着他们认为肖娜最后走过的路线，从第一自由卫理公会教堂一直走到距离她家不到两个街区的里德街和西第一街十字路口。与此同时，法医检测结果显示，肖娜的死因是头部和胸部受到严重的钝力创伤，这是由于从桁架桥坠落到地面造成的。她在坠落时还活着，在因伤离世前可能存活了长达30分钟。有性侵犯的证据，她紧身衣上的污渍检测出精液呈阳性。她的膝盖因粗糙的地板表面而擦伤，调查人员推测这是在她被囚禁的地方造成的。在过去的15个月里，石油城发生了三起凶杀案，每起案件中，受害者都是被其家庭成员杀害的。
Based on this information, investigators fronting inquiries into Shauna Howe's murder requested that various males in her family provide DNA samples to rule them out as suspects. Her stepfather, John Brown, was the first to be tested, followed by her uncles, Keith and Claire. Shauna's mother accepted this intrusion on her family, but drew the line when police wanted to test her 12-year-old son. Wanting to do anything he could to help find the person who harmed his younger sister, the boy agreed to participate. But none of these tests resulted in a positive match to the DNA sample found on Shauna's body suit. Investigators expanded their search for a suspect to every adult male known to Shauna and her family. They questioned neighbors, teachers, family friends, school workers, shop owners, and the fathers of Shauna's classmates and fellow girl scouts. Men who fit the description provided by Dan Paydon were given priority, such as Eldred Walker, better known as Ted, a tall, lanky, pizza shop worker known to request hugs from young female customers.
根据这些信息，负责调查肖娜·豪谋杀案的调查人员要求她家中的多名男性提供DNA样本，以排除他们作为嫌疑人的嫌疑。她的继父约翰·布朗是第一个接受测试的人，随后是她的叔叔基思和克莱尔。肖娜的母亲接受了这种对她家庭的侵扰，但当警察想要测试她12岁的儿子时，她划清了界限。为了尽其所能帮助找到伤害他妹妹的人，这个男孩同意参与测试。但这些测试没有一个与肖娜紧身衣上发现的DNA样本相匹配。调查人员将寻找嫌疑人的范围扩大到肖娜及其家人认识的所有成年男性。他们盘问了邻居、老师、家庭朋友、学校工人和店主，以及肖娜的同学和女童军同伴的父亲。符合丹·佩登提供的描述的男子被赋予了优先调查权，例如埃尔德雷德·沃克（更为人所知的名字是泰德），一个身材高大、瘦长的比萨店工人，众所周知他喜欢向年轻的女性顾客索要拥抱。
Shauna and her friends described Walker as creepy and went out of their way to avoid him. He was a smoker who was known to drive a small red car in the past, although he currently drove a Chevrolet Monte Carlo of a different color. When questioned, Walker claimed to know nothing about Shauna's murder and willingly submitted a DNA sample which did not match her killer. Two doors down from the Reed and West First intersection, there lived a man with an unsavory past named Michael Cusowitz. The day after Shauna's body was found, Cusowitz boarded a bus out of town and had not returned since. His unexplained and abrupt absence led him to become a suspect in the murder, but detectives were unable to track him down. On November 2, three days after Shauna's body was found, 150 people gathered to pay their respects in a memorial service, during which the 11-year-old's favorite country song, Hakey Breaky Heart by Billy Ray Cyrus, was played over the loudspeaker. Mourner's reminisced over fond memories of the young girl who was described by her mother as sassy. Tension was palpable as Mourner's eyed each other with suspicion, wondering whether the child's killer was standing amongst them.
肖娜和她的朋友们将沃克描述为令人毛骨悚然的人，并刻意避开他。他是一个烟民，过去曾被发现开一辆红色的轿车，尽管他目前开的是一辆不同颜色的雪佛兰蒙特卡洛。面对盘问时，沃克声称对肖娜的谋杀一无所知，并自愿提交了DNA样本，结果与杀害她的凶手不匹配。在里德街和西第一街十字路口的两门之隔，住着一个名叫迈克尔·库索维茨的、有着不光彩过去的男子。在肖娜的尸体被发现的第二天，库索维茨搭乘了一辆离开小镇的公共汽车，此后再也没有回来。他那无法解释的突然缺席使他成了这起谋杀案的嫌疑人，但侦探们无法追踪到他的下落。11月2日，在肖娜的尸体被发现三天后，150人聚集在一起参加悼念仪式，期间通过扬声器播放了这位11岁女孩最喜欢的乡村歌曲——比利·雷·赛勒斯的《阿基·布雷基·心》。哀悼者们回忆起这位被母亲形容为“厚颜无耻”的小女孩的美好回忆。哀悼者们互相猜疑，空气中弥漫着紧张的气氛，大家都在想凶手是否就站在他们中间。
Two weeks later, the lack of news surrounding Shauna Howe's murder only served to fuel rumors and speculation. Some locals considered Shauna's uncle Keith to be a suspect, believing it was too coincidental that he had led the search party to the site where his niece's body suit was discovered. With the killer at large, paranoia gripped the town, as parents forbade their children from roaming the streets and waited with them until they were safely on board the school bus. Graffiti appeared on a wall near 7th Street School, ominously warning students that they could be next. But police concluded this to be the work of a sick of Andal. Desperate for leads, police rummaged through Shauna's school desk and questioned her classmates. One of her fellow Girl Scouts recounted an interaction she had with Shauna prior to her death, in which Shauna presented two lollipops, explaining she was saving one for herself and the other for her mother. Local Mothers established a child safety group called Operation Kidwatch, with their first meeting attracting 100 townspeople. Venango County Sheriff Jean Price attended the event, advising the crowd that police were sifting through hundreds of pieces of information provided by the public, and urged the concerned parents to be patient. Some attendees admitted to arming their young daughters with mace, whilst one parent advised that cans of hairspray could be used as a low-tech substitute. The sheriff strongly warned against this behaviour, explaining that an attacker could easily turn such items against the girls.
两周后，围绕肖娜·豪谋杀案的消息匮乏，这反而助长了谣言和猜测。一些当地人认为肖娜的叔叔基思是嫌疑人，他们认为他带领搜寻队正好找到侄女紧身衣被发现的地点未免太巧合了。由于凶手仍然在逃，多疑情绪笼罩了整个小镇，父母们禁止孩子在街上游荡，并陪伴他们直到他们安全登上校车。第七街学校附近的一堵墙上出现了涂鸦，不祥地警告学生他们可能是下一个。但警方断定这是某个心理不健康的恶作剧者干的。由于极度渴望破案线索，警察搜查了肖娜的学校课桌并盘问了她的同学。她的一位女童军同伴回忆了她在死前与肖娜的一次互动，当时肖娜拿出了两个棒棒糖，解释说一个留给自己，另一个留给妈妈。当地母亲们成立了一个名为“儿童守望行动”的儿童安全组织，他们的第一次会议吸引了100名镇民参加。韦南戈县警长让·普赖斯出席了活动，并告知人群警方正在梳理公众提供的数百条信息，同时敦促焦急的父母保持耐心。一些与会者承认给年幼的女儿装备了梅斯防狼喷雾，而一位家长则建议可以用罐装发胶作为低技术含量的替代品。警长强烈警告不要有这种行为，并解释说袭击者很容易将这些物品反过来对付女孩。
Until police had answers, he recommended that young girls travelling groups of three or more, and their parents should know when to expect their children home, and to always have them call once they reached their destinations. On November 16th, the Oil City Rotary Club put forward a $500 reward for any information that led to the arrest of Shauna's killer. Meanwhile, posters featuring an image of an early 1980s dark red ultimobile Omega appeared around town, requesting anyone who had seen this type of vehicle to contact police. Hundreds of calls came through, leading police to investigate hundreds of similar model cars, none of which seemed to belong to the perpetrator. As the investigation languished for two years, the Oil City Council, Venango County Crime Stoppers and an anonymous donor provided funds to increase the reward money currently on offer to $11,500. Although this was a substantial amount for local residents, nobody came forward with information. The case continued to impact daily life in Oil City, with the streets quiet at night and people now locking their doors. Halloween would remain synonymous with Shauna Howe's murder, with the council voting to ban trick or treating after dark until her killer was found.
在警察得出答案之前，他建议年轻女孩们以三人或三人以上的小组出行，她们的父母应该知道预计孩子何时回家，并要求她们在到达目的地后务必打电话报平安。11月16日，石油城扶轮社悬赏500美元，以获取任何有助于逮捕肖娜凶手的线索。与此同时，印有1980年代早期深红色奥兹莫比尔·欧米茄汽车图像的海报出现在城镇各处，呼吁任何见过此类车辆的人与警方联系。数百个电话涌入，引导警方调查了数百辆类似型号的汽车，但似乎没有一辆属于作案者。随着调查陷入长达两年的停滞，石油城市政委员会、韦南戈县灭罪热线和一个匿名捐赠者提供资金，将当前提供的悬赏金提高到11,500美元。尽管对于当地居民来说这是一笔可观的金额，但没有人带着线索站出来。这起案件继续影响着石油城的日常生活，夜晚的街道一片寂静，人们现在都锁上了门。万圣节将依然与肖娜·豪的谋杀案联系在一起，市议会投票决定在找到凶手之前禁止在天黑后进行不给糖就捣蛋的活动。
As far as residents were concerned, little seemed to have been done to solve the case. Newspapers continued to report that police were investigating links between other crimes in the area, but none seemed to ever lead anywhere. According to a profile released by the Federal Bureau of Investigation, Shauna's killer was likely a Caucasian male of average size, possibly aged in his 20s, who worked a menial job and had his own form of transportation. His personality or behaviour may have undergone a noticeable shift since committing the murder, wherein he may have suddenly taken time off work, increased consumption of alcohol or drugs, and become obsessed with news reports on the investigation. Citizens were asked to recall anyone who may have been fired, skipped social gatherings, altered his meals or sleep, fought with friends, taken a sudden vacation, or appeared to be nervous or preoccupied around the time of Shauna's murder. Although the profile said it was unlikely the killer had struck before, FBI agents could not rule out the possibility he would strike again. In July 1995, police received a report of an attempted abduction on East Second Street, not far from where Shauna Howe was snatched two years and eight months earlier. The 22-year-old woman had been followed out of a bar by a man who grabbed her and tried to force her into the trunk of his vehicle.
就居民而言，似乎没有什么进展来解决这起案件。报纸继续报道称警方正在调查该地区其他罪行之间的联系，但似乎从来没有哪一条线索通向任何地方。根据联邦调查局发布的一份侧写，肖娜的凶手很可能是个体型中等的白人男性，年龄可能在20多岁，从事体力劳动，并拥有自己的交通工具。自从犯下谋杀案以来，他的个性和行为可能发生了显著的变化，比如他可能突然请假不工作、增加酒精或药物的摄入量，并且变得痴迷于有关调查的新闻报道。公民被要求回想一下在肖娜被谋杀前后，是否有任何人被解雇、无故缺席社交聚会、饮食或睡眠发生改变、与朋友吵架、突然度假，或者显得紧张和全神贯注。尽管侧写显示凶手以前不太可能作案，但联邦调查局特工不能排除他会再次作案的可能性。1995年7月，警方接到了一起在东第二街发生未遂绑架案的报告，地点距离肖娜·豪两年八个月前被掳走的地方不远。一名22岁的女子在从酒吧出来时被一名男子尾随，该男子抓住她并试图将她强行塞进汽车后备箱。
When she resisted, he slammed her head against the sidewalk. Realising he was unable to get the injured woman swiftly into the trunk, the man climbed into his car and sped away. Upon hearing the survivor's description of her attacker, police knew exactly where to look. The O'Brien brothers, Timothy and James, also known as Tim and Jim, were well known to police, having lived in oil city all of their lives. When they weren't in prison, the pair worked factory and gardening jobs where co-workers described being in a permanent state of anxiety around them, unsure when an uncomfortable encounter or violent explosion was coming. The brothers, both aged in their 20s, had clocked up a string of criminal charges over the years, including sexual offences against both adults and children. In some instances, the two would team up to commit their crimes, with James O'Brien generally considered to be the more dominant of the two due to his older brother's learning difficulties and mental health problems. At the time of the botched abduction, eldest brother Timothy O'Brien was serving a prison sentence for plying a 16-year-old girl with alcohol and taking pornographic images of her.
当她反抗时，他将她的头撞向人行道。意识到自己无法迅速将受伤的女子塞进后备箱后，该男子钻进车里，加速逃离。在听到幸存者对袭击者的描述后，警方确切地知道了该去哪里找人。奥布莱恩兄弟蒂莫西和詹姆斯（也叫蒂姆和吉姆）是警方熟知的人物，他们一生都住在石油城。当不在监狱里时，这两人从事工厂和园艺工作，同事们形容跟他们在一起时处于一种永久的焦虑状态，不确定什么时候会遇到令人不快的遭遇或爆发暴力冲突。这两兄弟都在20多岁，多年来背负了一连串的刑事指控，包括针对成年人和儿童的性犯罪。在某些情况下，这两人会联手犯罪，由于哥哥有学习障碍和心理健康问题，詹姆斯·奥布莱恩通常被认为是两人中较为主导的一个。在未遂绑架案发生时，老大蒂莫西·奥布莱恩正在服刑，罪名是向一名16岁女孩提供酒精并拍摄她的色情照片。
Therefore, his brother James was identified as the assailant and was convicted of first-degree felony attempted kidnapping, assault and unlawful restraint. When handing down a lengthy jail sentence, the judge declared James O'Brien to be a menace to society. Many had suspected the O'Brien brothers of being involved in Shauna Howe's murder, but there were several factors that excluded them as suspects. Firstly, Shauna's kidnapper had been described as a tall and slender man, but Timothy and James were heavy set. Secondly, they had both been in prison at the time Shauna was killed, securing them airtight alibis. A telephone pole bearing Shauna's photograph marked the street corner where she was abducted, serving as a constant reminder to locals about the unsolved case. And every year, on October 27, oil city residents held a candlelight vigil to walk Shauna's incomplete, final route home. Police provided an annual update on the status of their investigation, reminding the public of the details released in the FBI's criminal profile.
因此，他的弟弟詹姆斯被确定为袭击者，并被判犯有一级重罪未遂绑架、殴打和非法拘禁罪。在宣判漫长的刑期时，法官宣称詹姆斯·奥布莱恩是社会的危害。许多人曾怀疑奥布莱恩兄弟参与了肖娜·豪的谋杀案，但有几个因素排除了他们作为嫌疑人的可能。首先，肖娜的绑架者被描述为一个身材高大纤细的男子，但蒂莫西和詹姆斯体型偏胖。其次，肖娜被杀时两人都在监狱里，这为他们提供了无懈可击的不在场证明。一根贴有肖娜照片的电线杆标志着她被绑架的街角，不断提醒着当地人这起未解决的案件。每年的10月27日，石油城居民都会举行烛光晚会，走完肖娜未完成的回家最后路线。警方每年都会提供调查进展的更新，向公众提醒联邦调查局犯罪侧写中公布的细节。
Despite following leads to California, Ohio, New York and Kansas, they retained the belief that the child's killer was an oil city local. On October 29, 1997, almost five years to the day since Shauna Howe was kidnapped, four-year-old Shanae Freeman was playing with her friends Christian and Tiffany in a grassy area near the Ferncourt Council housing estate in Oil City. Christian had cut himself and ran inside his house to seek help from his mother. When he returned, Shanae was gone, and Tiffany reported that a man dressed in black had taken her into the woods. Word of the abduction spread quickly, and due to its occurrence right before Halloween, many feared Shauna House killer had struck again, with police questioning whether the month or holiday held some sort of significance to the perpetrator. A hundred volunteers searched for Shanae, who was wearing a long-sleeved white cotton dress adorned with love hearts, bright blue socks, white sneakers, and had her hair tied in pigtails using one red and one purple ribbon. As the day progressed and temperatures dropped, worries for Shanae increased as she was not wearing a coat, and her light dress would not be enough to keep her warm throughout the night. Amongst the search party was local teenager 17-year-old Nicholas Bowen.
尽管顺着线索追踪到了加利福尼亚州、俄亥俄州、纽约州和堪萨斯州，但他们依然坚信这个孩子的凶手是石油城的本地人。1997年10月29日，几乎就在肖娜·豪被绑架整整五年后，四岁的沙娜·弗里曼正在石油城芬考特市议会住宅区附近的草地上和她的朋友克里斯蒂安和蒂凡尼玩耍。克里斯蒂安割伤了自己，跑进屋里向母亲寻求帮助。当他回来时，沙娜已经不见了，蒂凡尼报告说一个穿黑衣服的男人把她带进了树林里。绑架的消息迅速传开，由于它发生在万圣节前夕，许多人担心肖娜·豪的凶手再次作案，警方甚至怀疑这个月份或节日对作案者具有某种特殊意义。一百名志愿者搜寻了沙娜，她穿着一件缀有红心图案的长袖白色棉质连衣裙、亮蓝色袜子、白色运动鞋，头发扎成双马尾，用一条红色和一条紫色的丝带系着。随着时间的推移，气温下降，人们对沙娜的担忧与日俱增，因为她没有穿外套，而她轻薄的裙子不足以在整个夜晚为她保暖。搜寻队伍中包括当地17岁的少年尼古拉斯·鲍恩。
Police suspicions were narrowed in on Bowen as he was dressed in black and witnesses had seen him playing with the children earlier that day after being suspended from school. Early in the search, he had offered a hug to Shanae's distraught mother, telling her not to worry, but he soon became agitated and wanted to go home. After very little questioning by the police, Bowen broke down, leading them into the woods and to Shanae's body. The four-year-old had been assaulted before being thrown into a ravine where she suffered a head injury that bled profusely. Panicking, Bowen kicked some dirt, sticks, and leaves over her before fleeing the scene, uncertain whether she was dead or alive. Twelve hours after she was reported missing, police charged Nicholas Bowen with Shanae Freeman's murder. Given the similarities to Shanae's house murder five years earlier, Nicholas Bowen seemed a likely suspect, but there was one problem. He was only 12 years old at the time Shanae was killed.
警方的怀疑集中在鲍恩身上，因为他穿着一身黑衣，而且目击者看到他在那天早些时候被学校停课后曾与这些孩子一起玩耍。在搜寻刚开始时，他曾主动拥抱沙娜心烦意乱的母亲，告诉她不要担心，但他很快变得焦躁不安，并想回家。在经过警方简短的盘问后，鲍恩崩溃了，他带领警察进入树林找到了沙娜的尸体。这个四岁的孩子在被扔进沟壑之前遭到了侵犯，并在那里头部受伤，大量流血。鲍恩惊慌失措地在她身上踢了一些泥土、树枝和树叶，然后逃离了现场，他不确定她究竟是死是活着。在她被报告失踪十二小时后，警方以谋杀沙娜·弗里曼的罪名起诉了尼古拉斯·鲍恩。鉴于五年前肖娜·豪谋杀案的相似之处，尼古拉斯·鲍恩似乎是一个可能的嫌疑人，但有一个问题。在沙娜被杀时，他只有12岁。
Any other possible connection was subsequently ruled out, with the similarities between the two crimes merely deemed a chilling coincidence. Later in 1997, in Armstrong County, a little over an hour south of Oil City, 32-year-old Richard Jobes and his 30-year-old wife Diane were charged with over 200 counts of sexual offences against three nurses who were hired to look after their sick children, a toddler with cerebral palsy, and an infant with a breathing disorder. The nurses alleged the husband and wife subjected them to numerous incidents of assault and indecent exposure, with one nurse claiming Diane held her down whilst her husband attempted to rape her. Most of the charges were dropped in return for a plea, with Richard Jobes convicted on 15 counts of indecent assault, and Diane Jobes convicted of simple assault, terroristic threats, and harassment. In sentencing, the judge stated, the depravity that went on is hard to comprehend, even as a judge. Shortly after her husband's sentencing, Diane Jobes told police she had lied about his alibi for the night of Shanae's house murder. At the time, the couple lived about eight miles from Shanae's family home. Following this revelation, police questioned Richard Jobes about his whereabouts on the night of October 27, 1992, but he denied having any involvement in Shanae's abduction.
此后，任何其他可能的联系都被排除，这两起犯罪之间的相似之处仅仅被认为是一个令人不寒而栗的巧合。1997年晚些时候，在距离石油城以南一个多小时车程的阿姆斯特朗县，32岁的理查德·乔布斯和他的30岁妻子黛安被控对三名护士实施了200多项性犯罪指控。这些护士受雇照顾他们生病的儿童，其中包括一个患有脑瘫的幼儿和一个有呼吸障碍的婴儿。护士指控这对夫妇对她们实施了多起殴打和猥亵暴露事件，其中一名护士声称黛安按住她，而她的丈夫则试图强奸她。作为认罪协议的一部分，大部分指控被撤销，理查德·乔布斯被判犯有15项猥亵罪，黛安·乔布斯被判犯有简单袭击、恐怖威胁和骚扰罪。在宣判时，法官表示，哪怕作为一名法官，所发生的堕落也是难以理解的。在丈夫宣判后不久，黛安·乔布斯告诉警察，她对沙娜·豪被害当晚丈夫的不在场证明撒了谎。当时，这对夫妇住在距离沙娜家大约八英里远的地方。在这番披露之后，警察就理查德·乔布斯在1992年10月27日晚上的行踪对其实施了盘问，但他否认自己与沙娜的绑架案有任何牵连。
His DNA was tested, but failed to reveal a match to Shanae's killer, and as there was no other evidence linking him to the crime, Jobes became just one more name in the list of over 2,000 men who had been questioned in relation to the murder. In the neighbouring state of New Jersey, the 1994 rape and murder of seven-year-old Megan Kanker by a repeat sexual offender resulted in the creation of Megan's law. The passing of this new federal bill meant the names and addresses of known sex offenders were entered into a database, enabling law enforcement to supervise their movements following their release from prison. In cases of high-risk offenders, the law allowed for limited community notification as well, meaning citizens were made aware when serious sexual offenders moved into their neighbourhoods. During this time, Shanae's mother Lucy learned how to search the Oil City sex offender registry, and was shocked to discover that 20 registered sexual offenders were living within blocks of her house alone. In mid-1999, police searched a two-and-a-half-story yellow brick home on Reed Street near the intersection where Shanae was taken almost seven years prior, concentrating on the basement and space under the back porch stairs. At the time of Shanae's murder, the house had been rented by Michael Cusowitz, the man of questionable character who suddenly left town on a bus and disappeared the day after the 11-year-old's body was discovered.
他的DNA经过了测试，但未能显示与沙娜的凶手相匹配，由于没有其他证据将他与这起犯罪联系起来，乔布斯成为了曾就该谋杀案接受盘问的2000多名男子的名单中的又一个普通名字。在邻近的新泽西州，1994年七岁女孩梅根·坎克尔被一名惯犯强奸并杀害的事件促成了《梅根法案》的诞生。这项新联邦法案的通过意味着已被确定的性犯罪者的姓名和地址被输入了一个数据库，使执法部门能够在他们出狱后监督他们的行踪。对于高风险罪犯，该法律还允许进行有限的社区通知，这意味着当严重的性犯罪者搬进他们的社区时，公民会知晓。在此期间，沙娜的母亲露西学会了如何查询石油城的性犯罪者登记册，并震惊地发现仅在她家附近的几个街区内就生活着20名登记在册的性犯罪者。1999年中期，警方搜查了里德街上一栋两层半的黄色砖房，该房子靠近沙娜近七年前被掳走的十字路口，搜查重点放在地下室和后廊楼梯下的空间。在沙娜被谋杀时，这所房子曾被迈克尔·库索维茨租下，也就是那个在11岁女孩尸体被发现的第二天突然乘公共汽车离开小镇并消失的品行可疑的男子。
He had been a person of interest since the early stages of the investigation, as he vaguely fit the description of the tall, thin male suspect. Although police refused to comment on what they were looking for in this latest search of the property, local media speculated whether they were determining if the scuffs on Shanae's knees may have been caused by the flooring in Cusowitz's former home. But once again, their efforts led nowhere. Police eventually tracked Michael Cusowitz down to a Connecticut prison where he was serving time for drug-related charges. He was questioned multiple times in relation to Shanae's murder, and despite having no evidence to link him to the crime, he remained a strong person of interest. Upon learning of the search of his former residence, Cusowitz made the unusual move of writing a letter from prison to Oil City's local newspaper, The Derrick, in which he wrote, Well, God rest her soul, and with all due respect for the Howe family, her death has been a misery to me. Misery to the point of seven years worth of questions, blood tests, polygraph tests, and more done to me, because I'm told, being a male with a minor criminal record, I am a major suspect.
自从调查初期开始，他就一直是被重点关注的对象，因为他的体貌特征隐约符合那个身材高大、体型偏瘦的男性嫌疑人。尽管警方拒绝就这次搜查物业的具体目标发表评论，但当地媒体纷纷猜测，他们是否在查明肖娜膝盖上的擦伤是否是由库索维茨前住所的地板造成的。然而，他们的努力再次石沉大海。警方最终在康涅狄格州的一所监狱里找到了迈克尔·库索维茨，当时他正因涉毒指控在服刑。他曾多次就肖娜的谋杀案接受讯问，尽管没有证据将他与这起犯罪联系起来，但他依然是一个重大的嫌疑人。得知前住所被搜查后，库索维茨做出了一个不同寻常的举动，他从狱中给油城的当地报纸《德里克报》写了一封信。他在信中写道：‘愿上帝安息她的灵魂，怀着对豪尔一族的无限敬意，她的死一直是我心中的痛苦。这种痛苦长达七年，伴随着无数的问题、血液测试、测谎仪测试以及针对我的种种调查，因为我被告知，作为一个有着轻微犯罪记录的男性，我是主要嫌疑人。’
Later that year, on the seventh anniversary of Shanae's abduction, children were once again reminded to stay off the streets and warned to observe the long-running ban on trickle-treating after dark. Police made their annual statement to the press, claiming they had obtained evidence they believed could help in presenting a prosecutable case. The evidence was currently being analysed by the FBI, with Oil City police stating, We are feeling very good about the case as it stands today. Detective Richard Graham had served on the Pennsylvania State Police Force since 1970. At the time of Shanae Howe's disappearance, he was working as a patrolman and assisted in the search, but beyond that, he had little involvement with the case. Then, in 1995, the lead investigator in Shanae's murder retired, and six months later, the cold case was assigned to Detective Graham. Like many struggling working-class towns, Oil City law enforcement had limited resources, which meant they had to prioritise their cases according to a variety of factors.
同年晚些时候，在肖娜遭绑架七周年纪念日那天，孩子们再次被提醒远离街头，并被警告遵守长期以来关于天黑后禁止不给糖就捣蛋的禁令。警方发表了年度新闻声明，声称他们已经获得了他们认为有助于提起公诉的证据。这些证据目前正在接受联邦调查局的分析，油城警方表示：‘就目前的情况来看，我们对这起案件感到非常乐观。’侦探理查德·格雷厄姆自1970年起就在宾夕法尼亚州警察局服役。肖娜·豪尔失踪时，他是一名巡警，曾协助搜寻工作，但除此之外，他与该案的交集并不多。后来，在1995年，肖娜谋杀案的主负责调查员退休了，六个月后，这起积案被指派给了格雷厄姆侦探。像许多苦苦挣扎的工人阶级城镇一样，油城的执法部门资源有限，这意味着他们必须根据各种因素对案件进行优先级排序。
Cold cases, or those where little new information was coming in, were often given the lowest priority. Complicating matters were the many problems that inevitably arise over lengthy criminal investigations, including misplaced evidence, poor record-keeping and lost leads. Although Detective Graham's workload consisted of up to 70 open files at any given time, Shanae Howe's murder continued to haunt him, and he often spent his own spare time revisiting the case. He sought the services of noted criminal profiler, Colonel Robert Restler, who had helped catch son of Sam Keller, David Berkowitz, and whose techniques inspired the crime thriller, Silence of the Lambs. When added to the investigation, Colonel Restler presented the possibility that Shanae Howe had been abducted by more than one perpetrator, a theory that had not previously been considered by police. He referenced the Dan Payden's witness account of the abduction, during which he hadn't seen Shanae being forced into the vehicle, nor had he seen the perpetrator jump behind the wheel of the vehicle, despite arriving at the side of her abduction just seconds after she was snatched. To Colonel Restler, Dan's account made much more sense if the perpetrator had handed Shana to an accomplice before running away on foot. This theory made sense to Detective Graham, as when he had initially revisited Shanae's cold case photographs, he noticed a new detail.
积案，即那些几乎没有新线索进展的案件，通常被赋予最低的优先级。让情况更加复杂的是漫长刑事调查中不可避免会出现的诸多问题，包括证据错置、记录保存不善以及线索丢失。尽管格雷厄姆侦探的工作量在任何特定时间都高达70起未结档案，但肖娜·豪尔的谋杀案仍然萦绕在他的心头，他经常利用自己的业余时间重新审视这起案件。他寻求了著名犯罪侧写师罗伯特·雷斯特勒上校的帮助，后者曾协助抓获‘山姆之子’凯利、大卫·伯科维茨，其技术还启发了犯罪惊悚片《沉默的羔羊》。当雷斯特勒上校加入调查时，他提出了肖娜·豪尔可能是被一名以上的作案者绑架的可能性，这一理论此前并未被警方考虑过。他参考了丹·佩登对绑架案的目击陈述，在这起陈述中，丹并没有看到肖娜被强行塞进车里，也没有看到作案者跳上驾驶座，尽管他在肖娜被抓走几秒钟后就赶到了她被绑架的路边。对雷斯特勒上校来说，如果作案者在徒步逃跑前将肖娜交给了同伙，丹的陈述就变得更加合乎逻辑了。这个理论对格雷厄姆侦探来说很合情合理，因为当他最初重新审视肖娜的积案照片时，他注意到一个新的细节。
At the time her body was discovered, there was a shoe print on her cheek. This suggested Shanae's attack had been violent, but as there were no ligature marks around her wrists or ankles, she was likely held captive without restraint, a task requiring more than one perpetrator. When DNA samples were first collected from Shanae's body suit, some detectives had considered the possibility that DNA could have been transferred independently of her murder, as the home she lived in was not particularly well kept, and many people came and went. With recent advancements in DNA testing, Detective Graham ordered a test on a swab that had been taken from Shanae's mouth, with the swab returning a positive match for the seminal DNA that was on her clothing. The lab technician told the detective, if you find the DNA match, you'll have your killer. Thus, Detective Graham focused his efforts on collecting and testing DNA from as many potential suspects as possible. In late 2001, Detective Graham's investigation into an unsolved violent robbery brought him to the Venango County Jail to question a possible suspect, Timothy O'Brien. The eldest of the O'Brien brothers was serving time for an unrelated burglary, whilst his younger sibling James was completing his sentence for the 1995 attempted kidnapping of the 22-year-old woman.
在她尸体被发现时，她的脸颊上有一个鞋印。这表明肖娜遭受了暴力袭击，但由于她的手腕或脚踝周围没有勒痕，她很可能是在没有受到束缚的情况下被软禁的，这项任务需要不止一名作案者。当首次从肖娜的连体衣中采集DNA样本时，一些侦探曾考虑过DNA可能是在谋杀之外独立转移的可能性，因为她居住的房子保持得并不是特别好，而且人员流动很大。随着DNA检测技术的最新进展，格雷厄姆侦探下令对从肖娜口腔中提取的拭子进行检测，该拭子与她衣服上的精液DNA呈阳性匹配。实验室技术员告诉这位侦探：‘如果你找到了DNA匹配者，你就能找到凶手。’因此，格雷厄姆侦探将精力集中在从尽可能多的潜在嫌疑人身上收集和检测DNA上。2001年末，格雷厄姆侦探对一起未破的暴力抢劫案的调查将他带到了韦南戈县监狱，以讯问一名可能的嫌疑人蒂莫西·奥布莱恩。奥布莱恩兄弟中的老大当时正在因无关的入室盗窃罪服刑，而他的弟弟詹姆斯则在完成他因1995年企图绑架一名22岁女子而被判处的刑罚。
As had become a habit when questioning any male criminal in Oil City, after questioning Timothy O'Brien about the robbery, Detective Graham requested he provide a DNA sample to rule him out of the Shanae Howe murder investigation. Timothy was startled but agreed, before saying he had to check with his lawyer first. Something about the way he said this made the hairs on the back of the detective's neck prickle. Timothy O'Brien's DNA sample came back a negative for a match to Shanae's killer, but Detective Graham couldn't shake the feeling that something wasn't right. Then in early December 2001, he met with State Parole Agent Ed Flick to discuss an unrelated matter when the conversation turned to Shanae's murder. Ed remarked he always felt the O'Brien brothers could be involved, despite the fact that they were both in prison at the time of the crime, and therefore had solid alibis. It suddenly occurred to Detective Graham that when he inherited Shanae's case, he had simply relied on notes in the file that said the O'Brien brothers had been in prison at the time of Shanae's abduction, but had never confirmed these details for himself. To satisfy his curiosity, he decided to double check the official records, and what he discovered, rocked him to the core.
就像在油城讯问任何男性罪犯时养成的习惯一样，在就抢劫案讯问了蒂莫西·奥布莱恩后，格雷厄姆侦探要求他提供一份DNA样本，以将他排除在肖娜·豪尔谋杀案的调查之外。蒂莫西吓了一跳，但随后表示同意，不过他说他必须先征求律师的意见。他说话的方式让侦探脖子后面的汗毛都竖了起来。蒂莫西·奥布莱恩的DNA样本与肖娜的凶手比对结果为阴性，但格雷厄姆侦探挥之不去地觉得有些不对劲。接着，在2001年12月上旬，他与州假释官埃德·弗利克会面讨论一件不相关的事情时，谈话转到了肖娜的谋杀案上。埃德评论说，他一直觉得奥布莱恩兄弟可能参与其中，尽管事实上他们在案发时都在监狱里，因此有着坚实的不在场证明。格雷厄姆侦探突然意识到，当他接手肖娜的案件时，他只是简单地依赖于档案中的笔记，这些笔记称奥布莱恩兄弟在肖娜遭绑架时在监狱里，但他从未亲自证实过这些细节。为了满足自己的好奇心，他决定仔细检查官方记录，而他所发现的内容深深震撼了他。
The records showed that while the O'Brien brothers had indeed been arrested around the time of Shanae's abduction, they had made bail, and were not in police custody on the night she went missing. Later that month, Detective Graham was transferred to a new unit, effectively removing him from Shanae's case. Before the transfer, he put in a final request for one of his fellow officers to visit James O'Brien in the Mercer State Correctional Facility to obtain his DNA sample. His request was obliged in early January 2002, and whilst awaiting the results, the case took another surprising turn. On January 9, 2002, a former cellmate of Timothy O'Brien told police they had been playing cards together when the prison went into lockdown during the September 11 terror attacks the previous year. According to the inmate, Timothy confessed to Shanae's murder during the game, saying he forced the young girl into the trunk of a vehicle before throwing her off a bridge. Then, in early February 2002, Detective Graham received a phone call from the forensic technician who had worked on Shanae's case for years, wanting him to be the first to hear the news. The results of James O'Brien's DNA test had returned a match for the DNA found on Shanae.
记录显示，虽然奥布莱恩兄弟确实在肖娜遭绑架前后被捕，但他们已经取保候审，在她失踪当晚并不在警方羁押下。当月晚些时候，格雷厄姆侦探被调到一个新的单位，这实际上将他从肖娜的案子中调离了。在调离之前，他提出了最后的要求，让他的同僚之一去莫瑟州立惩戒所拜访詹姆斯·奥布莱恩以获取他的DNA样本。他的请求在2002年1月上旬得到了满足，在等待结果的同时，案件迎来了另一个令人惊讶的转折。2002年1月9日，蒂莫西·奥布莱恩的一名狱友告诉警方，在前一年9月11日恐怖袭击期间监狱封锁时，他们一直在一起打牌。据这名犯人交代，蒂莫西在牌局中承认了肖娜的谋杀案，称他强迫这个年轻女孩进入汽车后备箱，然后把她扔下了一座桥。随后，在2002年2月上旬，格雷厄姆侦探接到了为肖娜案工作多年的法医技术员的电话，对方希望他是第一个听到这个消息的人。詹姆斯·奥布莱恩的DNA测试结果与在肖娜身上发现的DNA相匹配。
Following these breakthroughs, a team of law enforcement officers made up of state police and FBI agents met to strategize their next steps. James O'Brien's DNA indicated he had contact with Shanae, but didn't prove he was responsible for her death, and all they had linking Timothy O'Brien to the crime was the story provided by an unreliable jailhouse snitch. Law enforcement had to tread carefully before making an arrest, as any decent lawyer could tear the case to shreds. There were still elements of the crime that didn't add up. Neither Timothy nor James O'Brien matched Dan Payden's witness description of the man who snatched Shanae, nor did either of them drive a small red sedan at the time of the attack. Investigators speculated as to whether a third accomplice may have also been involved, and their suspicions returned to Ted Walker, the tall, lanky, local pizza shop worker who was known to act inappropriately around young female customers. Not only was he known to Shana, but one of the O'Brien brothers had been staying at his residence around the time of her abduction, assisting him with maintenance jobs. During the early stages of their investigation, police had questioned Ted Walker about a red car parked behind his house, which shared similarities to the description provided by Dan Payden.
在这些突破之后，由州警察和联邦调查局特工组成的执法人员小组开会制定下一步行动策略。詹姆斯·奥布莱恩的DNA表明他与肖娜有过接触，但并未证明他对她的死负责，而他们将蒂莫西·奥布莱恩与犯罪联系起来的唯一依据是不可靠的狱中线人提供的一番说辞。执法部门在实施逮捕前必须谨小慎微，因为任何像样的律师都能把这个案件撕得粉碎。案件中仍然有一些不合逻辑的元素。蒂莫西和詹姆斯·奥布莱恩都不符合丹·佩登对绑架肖娜的男子的目击描述，袭击发生时两人也没有驾驶一辆红色的微型轿车。调查人员推测是否还有第三名同伙也卷入其中，他们的怀疑再次指向了特德·沃克，这个当地披萨店身材高大、瘦骨嶙峋的员工，他以在年轻女性顾客面前行为不端而闻名。他不仅是肖娜认识的人，而且奥布莱恩兄弟之一在肖娜遭绑架前后曾借住在他家，帮他做一些维护工作。在调查的初期阶段，警方曾就停在他家房子后面的一辆红车讯问过特德·沃克，这辆车与丹·佩登提供的描述有相似之处。
Although Walker had explained the vehicle was a project he was working on, and it was currently inoperable, original investigators never confirmed whether the car was capable of being driven, and it had long since been sent to the scrap heap. Ted Walker had been questioned numerous times over the years, but had a habit of changing details every time, whilst giving answers that were noticeably well thought out and wordy. As the investigative spotlight narrowed in on Walker, he was brought in for questioning once again, during which he was informed that police had DNA evidence and witness statements linking the O'Brien brothers to Shanae's murder. This information prompted Walker to change his story yet again, telling investigators he may have taken in some real bad people, who may have done a disgusting thing. He then admitted he and the O'Brien brothers had been joking about the incompetence of oil city police when they came up with what they thought was a funny prank. They would snatch a child in front of a witness on Halloween, and watch as the inept cops made fools of themselves running around looking for the child. They aimed to grab someone they knew so their victim wouldn't be too scared, and once their actions had caused a bit of chaos, they would return the child safely. As investigators continued to mount their case against Ted Walker and the O'Brien brothers, they were alerted to a call made to the local fire department the night after Walker had told them about the abduction plot he concocted with the O'Brien's.
尽管沃克解释说这辆车是他正在修理的一个项目，目前无法行驶，但最初的调查人员从未确认这辆车是否具备行驶能力，而且它很久以前就被送去了废品回收站。多年来，特德·沃克曾多次接受讯问，但他每次都有更改细节的习惯，同时给出的答案明显经过深思熟虑且冗长。随着调查的聚光灯缩小到沃克身上，他又一次被带去接受讯问，在此期间，他被告知警方拥有将奥布莱恩兄弟与肖娜谋杀案联系起来的DNA证据和目击者证词。这些信息促使沃克再次改口，他告诉调查人员，他可能收留了一些非常糟糕的人，他们可能做了一件令人作呕的事。然后他承认，他和奥布莱恩兄弟在嘲笑油城警方无能时，想出了一个他们认为很好笑的恶作剧。他们要在万圣节当着目击者的面绑架一个孩子，然后看着无能的警察像傻子一样到处跑着找孩子。他们的目标是抓一个他们认识的人，这样他们的受害者就不会太害怕，一旦他们的行动引起了一点混乱，他们就会把孩子安全地送回去。正当调查人员继续针对特德·沃克和奥布莱恩兄弟构建证据链时，他们接到警报，在沃克向他们讲述他与奥布莱恩兄弟策划的绑架阴谋的当晚，当地消防局接到了一通报警电话。
A neighbour of Walker's caught sight of the man burning something behind his house, believed to have been a mattress. Investigators obtained a search warrant for Walker's residence, and on the evening of March 14, 2002, they converged on Laurel Avenue, a quiet, unsealed road on the edge of town lined with ramshackle derelict houses with overgrown, neglected yards. With no evidence uncovered during the search of Ted Walker's property, investigators remained at a loss as to the location where Shauna had been held captive before she was killed. Ted Walker was at work at the time the warrant was enacted, and police refused to make an official statement to reporters. Regardless, word soon spread that the search was related to Shauna Howe, and local news ran the story alongside a picture of Walker. When Dan Payden saw the story, he placed a call to the police, telling them he was 90% certain that Walker was the tall, thin man he had seen smoking a cigarette near the Reed and West First Street intersection almost 10 years prior. When Walker was next interviewed by police, he admitted that on the night of October 27, 1992, he approached Shauna Howe and asked her about her Girl Scout cookies, before giving her a hug and handing her over to Timothy O'Brien as part of their abduction prank. Walker claimed he returned home, and a few minutes later, Timothy and James O'Brien arrived at his house with Shauna, before taking her upstairs.
沃克的邻居看到那个男人在房子后面烧东西，据信是一个床垫。调查人员获得了对沃克住所的搜查令，2002年3月14日晚，他们包围了月桂大道——那是镇边缘一条安静的、未硬化的道路，两旁是破旧荒废的房子和长满野草、疏于打理的院子。由于在对特德·沃克财产的搜查中没有发现任何证据，调查人员仍然无法确定肖娜在被杀害前被软禁的地点。搜查令执行时特德·沃克正在上班，警方拒绝向记者发表官方声明。无论如何，搜查与肖娜·豪尔有关的消息很快传开，当地新闻播报了这则报道，并配上了沃克的照片。当丹·佩登看到这则报道时，他给警方打了个电话，告诉他们他有90%的把握确信，沃克就是他将近10年前在里德街和西一街交叉口附近看到的那名抽烟的高瘦男子。当沃克下一次接受警方讯问时，他承认在1992年10月27日晚，他走近肖娜·豪尔，向她询问女童军饼干的事，然后给了她一个拥抱，并作为他们绑架恶作剧的一部分，把她交给了蒂莫西·奥布莱恩。沃克声称他回了家，几分钟后，蒂莫西和詹姆斯·奥布莱恩带着肖娜来到他家，然后把她带到了楼上。
Walker claimed he hadn't said anything about this to police earlier, because he feared for his son's life. On March 19, 2002, detectives approached James O'Brien with the news that his DNA had been linked to Shauna. James reportedly dropped his head to his lap and said, Alright, I'm not going to sit here and deny what you already know. However, when reporters arrived to interview James, he remained defiant, telling local newspaper The Derrick, I didn't do it. So I wasn't going to admit to it. I have a clear conscience. I don't know how you would go on living knowing you were responsible for a child's death like that. I understand why they want it solved. It's a horrific crime.
沃克声称他之前没有向警方提及此事，是因为他担心自己儿子的生命安全。2002年3月19日，侦探们找到詹姆斯·奥布莱恩，告诉他其DNA已与肖娜联系在一起的消息。据报道，詹姆斯把头埋在膝盖上说：‘好吧，我不会坐在这里否认你们已经知道的事情。’然而，当记者们赶来采访詹姆斯时，他依然态度挑衅，对当地报纸《德里克报》说：‘我没做过。所以我不会承认。我问心无愧。我不知道带着对一个孩子的死负有责任的心情要怎么活下去。我理解他们为什么想要破案。这是一桩可怕的罪行。’
Despite all the information and evidence that police now had pointing to the three culprits, the district attorney needed a watertight case before proceeding with an arrest. With each defendant entitled to two lawyers, Venango County needed to procure the budget to go to trial and wanted time to ensure the prosecution's case would result in a conviction. The O'Brien brothers didn't present a threat to the public as James was still in prison and Timothy was currently under house arrest. Over the following months, investigators worked to solidify their case as the district attorney awaited the funds to proceed the trial. Meanwhile, in 2003, Timothy O'Brien was convicted of two child sex offences against a six-year-old girl and an 11-year-old boy that occurred in 1999 and 2000. He was sentenced to 33 months to five years in prison. At a subsequent hearing to determine the threat he presented to the public under Megan's law, he was diagnosed with both antisocial personality disorder and pedophilic tendencies and labelled as sexually violent predator, the most severe classification of sex offender. Two more years passed before authorities were ready to take Shawna House case to trial.
尽管警方现在掌握了指向这三名罪魁祸首的所有信息和证据，但地方检察官在提起诉讼前需要一份天衣无缝的案件。由于每个被告都有权拥有两名律师，韦南戈县需要筹集预算来进行审判，并希望有时间确保检方的案件能够定罪。奥布莱恩兄弟没有对公众构成威胁，因为詹姆斯仍在狱中，而蒂莫西当时正处于软禁中。在接下来的几个月里，随着地方检察官等待审判资金的到位，调查人员努力巩固他们的案件。与此同时，在2003年，蒂莫西·奥布莱恩因两起分别发生于1999年和2000年的针对一名6岁女孩和一名11岁男孩的儿童性犯罪而被定罪。他被判处33个月至5年监禁。在随后的听证会上，根据《梅根法案》确定他对公众构成的威胁，他被诊断出患有反社会人格障碍和恋童倾向，并被贴上了性暴力掠夺者的标签，这是性犯罪者中最严重的分类。又过了两年，当局才准备好将肖娜·豪尔的案件提交审判。
On July 3, 2004, Timothy and James O'Brien were arrested and charged with first and second degree murder, rape, involuntary deviate sexual intercourse, and kidnapping. It was the biggest news story in Oil City's recent history. Journalists obtained the affidavit for the O'Brien's arrest, which included details about Ted Walker's role in the abduction and news crews converged on his house for comment. He expressed relief that police had finally caught the culprits, saying, Walker maintained the only reason he had been interviewed about the case in the past was that he matched the description of Shawna's abductor. He denied involvement in the crime, asserting, He maintained any admission of guilt he made was coerced by police threatening to take his son away. He also alleged police planted evidence when they searched his home, adding that he had no respect for anyone that would hurt a child.
2004年7月3日，蒂莫西和詹姆斯·奥布莱恩被捕，并被指控犯有一级和二级谋杀罪、强奸罪、非自愿异性恋性交罪以及绑架罪。这是油城近代史上最大的新闻。记者们获取了奥布莱恩兄弟被捕的宣誓书，其中包含关于特德·沃克在绑架中所扮演角色的细节，新闻车蜂拥至他家进行采访。他对警方终于抓获罪魁祸首表示宽慰，并称：沃克坚称，他过去之所以接受该案的讯问，只是因为他符合肖娜绑架者的体貌特征。他否认参与了这起犯罪，断言：他坚称自己做出的任何认罪都是在警方威胁要带走他儿子的逼迫下做出的。他还指控警方在搜查他的家时栽赃证据，并补充说他看不起任何会伤害孩子的人。
The next day of July 4, state police officers sat outside Ted Walker's multi-story derelict house on Laurel Avenue, documenting all the comings and goings, before placing him under arrest without incident at approximately 11.45am. Under questioning, Walker quickly realized his lies had caught up with him. The next day, he accepted a plea deal, agreeing to plead guilty to kidnapping and third-degree murder, which carried a prison term of 20 to 40 years. In return for his testimony against the two O'Brien brothers, he would avoid the more serious charges for first or second-degree murder, which carried a possible death sentence and life in prison, respectively. Following his arrest, Ted Walker was interviewed by state trooper Vernon Brown, during which he provided a more detailed account of his version of the events of October 1992. According to Walker, the initial plan he concocted with the O'Brien brothers was supposed to be a prank to upset the oil city police department by making them look incompetent. They intended to grab a child in plain sight on Halloween night, making it obvious enough that the police would be called. The trio would then keep the child for 10 to 15 minutes before dropping them off safely at home.
第二天7月4日，州警察局警官坐在月桂大道上特德·沃克那栋多层破旧房屋外，记录着所有的人员进出情况，随后在大约上午11点45分将他无冲突地逮捕。在讯问下，沃克很快意识到他的谎言已经败露。第二天，他接受了一项认罪协议，同意承认犯有绑架罪和三级谋杀罪，这将面临20至40年的监禁。作为对他出庭指证奥布莱恩兄弟的回报，他将免受可能分别判处死刑和终身监禁的更严重的一级或二级谋杀罪指控。被捕后，特德·沃克接受了州骑警弗农·布朗的讯问，在讯问期间，他对自己版本的1992年10月事件经过提供了更详细的描述。据沃克所说，他和奥布莱恩兄弟最初策划的计划本应是一个恶作剧，目的是通过让油城警察局显得无能来气气他们。他们打算在万圣节之夜在大庭广众之下抓走一个孩子，让警方注意到并报警。然后，这三人会将孩子扣留10到15分钟，之后再将他们安全地送回家。
They originally planned on taking the male friend of Walker's son, but decided a girl was a more worthwhile target, as she might cause more of a sensation. Once this plan was formed, the O'Brien brothers discussed the abduction with increasing frequency and intensity. Then, on the night of October 27, 1992, Walker drove to the A-plus convenience store to purchase coffee and cigarettes, when he saw the O'Brien's drive-by in one of his fixer-upper cars, a red Chevrolet Chevette, which the pair had taken without his permission. Walker followed them to the west-first and Reed Street intersection where both cars pulled over. When he approached the red Chevette, Timothy O'Brien told him, we've bumped up the plan. The O'Brien's explained they wanted to snatch a child that night, and they didn't care who it was. At that moment, the men saw 11-year-old Shauna Howe walking alone down the darkened street. Walker approached her, asking if she was selling Girl Scout cookies and requesting she give him a hug.
他们最初计划带走沃克儿子的男性朋友，但后来决定女孩是一个更有价值的目标，因为她可能会引起更大的轰动。这个计划一旦成型，奥布莱恩兄弟便以越来越高的频率和强度讨论起这起绑架案。然后，在1992年10月27日晚，沃克开车去A-plus便利店买咖啡和香烟，当时他看到奥布莱恩兄弟开着他的一辆待修车——一辆红色的雪佛兰切维特（Chevrolet Chevette）从他身边驶过，这俩人是未经他允许拿走这辆车的。沃克一路跟踪他们来到西一街和里德街的交叉口，两辆车都在路边停了下来。当他走近红色的切维特时，蒂莫西·奥布莱恩告诉他：‘我们把计划提前了。’奥布莱恩兄弟解释说，他们想今晚就绑架一个孩子，而且他们不在乎是谁。就在这时，这几个男n人看到11岁的肖娜·豪尔正独自一人走在黑暗的街道上。沃克走过去，问她是不是在卖女童军饼干，并要求她给他一个拥抱。
He then scooped her up and shoved her toward Timothy O'Brien, who was standing at the open passenger side door of the two-door Chevette, where his brother sat at the wheel. The front passenger seat had already been pulled forward, enabling the men to quickly shove Shauna into the back seat. Once the brothers had Shauna in the car, Walker jumped in his own vehicle and circled the block. When he returned, the red Chevette had gone. He stopped for more coffee and a loaf of bread before heading home, and minutes later, the O'Brien brothers arrived with Shauna under their arms. They carried her upstairs while Walker started to prepare dinner for his son in the kitchen. He claimed that at this point, he still believed the situation unfolding was just part of the original prank the trio had planned. Whilst he was cooking spaghetti, Walker heard a female voice crying from above.
然后他把她抱起来，把她推向蒂莫西·奥布莱恩，后者正站在那辆双门切维特打开的副驾驶车门旁，他的兄弟则坐在方向盘后。前排乘客座椅已经被向前拉开，以便两人迅速将肖娜推进后座。一旦兄弟俩把肖娜弄进车里，沃克就跳进自己的车里绕了街区一圈。等他回来时，那辆红色的切维特已经不见了。他停下来买更多的咖啡和一条面包，然后开车回家，几分钟后，奥布莱恩兄弟带着夹在胳膊底下的肖娜赶到了。他们把她抬到楼上，而沃克则开始在厨房为他的儿子准备晚饭。他声称，此时他仍然相信正在发生的事件只是三人原计划中恶作剧的一部分。当他在煮通心粉时，沃克听到楼上传来一个女孩子的哭声。
He stormed upstairs to the room where Shauna was being held and called through the door, ordering the brothers to get the hell out of his house. Timothy O'Brien appeared, telling him to mind his own business and worry about his own son. Walker grabbed his son and left the residence for a short time, and when he returned, the brothers and Shauna were no longer there. Furious, the O'Brien had taken Shauna to his home. Walker later kicked the pair out when they returned without the girl later that night. Detectives didn't fully trust Ted Walker's version of events, believing he spun his tail to make himself out to be an innocent party. But as they relied on his testimony to secure a conviction for the crime that had hung over Royal City for nearly 13 years, they continued to work with him. And for the first time since Shauna Howe was abducted, things moved quickly.
他冲上楼去到关押肖娜的房间，隔着门大喊，命令兄弟俩滚出他的家。蒂莫西·奥布莱恩出现，告诉他少管闲事，管好他自己的儿子就行。沃克抓起儿子离开了住所一小段时间，等他回来时，兄弟俩和肖娜已经不在那里了。愤怒的奥布莱恩把肖娜带到了他自己的家。当天晚些时候，当这俩人回来时却没有带那个女孩，沃克随后将他们赶了出去。侦探们并不完全信任特德·沃克版本的事件经过，认为他编造谎言是为了把自己打扮成无辜的一方。但由于他们依赖他的证词来为这起压在皇家城头顶将近13年的罪行定罪，他们选择继续与他合作。而且，自从肖娜·豪尔被绑架以来，事情第一次进展得如此迅速。
Due to the high-profile nature of the case, the trial was moved out of Venango County after it was determined the accused were unlikely to receive a fair local trial. The court ruled that 39-year-old Timothy O'Brien and 33-year-old James O'Brien be tried together, followed by a separate trial for 46-year-old Ted Walker. When the O'Brien brothers' trial commenced, members of Shauna's family sat quietly in the courtroom. Ted Walker took the stand to testify against the brothers, but once again parts of his story changed. In his initial confession, he told police he was at home when he saw the O'Brien brothers carry Shauna upstairs. But he now claimed that when he returned home from buying coffee and bread, his son informed him that the O'Brien's had taken someone upstairs. He didn't ask his son any questions, but assumed the person he was referring to was Shauna. The defense argued that Walker was the sole culprit of the rape and murder and was lying in order to save himself.
由于该案的高度备受瞩目，在确定被告不太可能在当地获得公正审判后，审判被移出了韦南戈县。法院裁定，39岁的蒂莫西·奥布莱恩和33岁的詹姆斯·奥布莱恩一同受审，随后对46岁的特德·沃克进行单独审判。当奥布莱恩兄弟的审判开始时，肖娜家人的成员静静地坐在法庭里。特德·沃克出庭作证指控这对兄弟，但他的部分说辞再次发生了变化。在他最初的供述中，他告诉警方他当时在家，看到奥布莱恩兄弟把肖娜抬上楼。但他现在改口称，当他买完咖啡和面包回到家时，他的儿子告诉他奥布莱恩兄弟把某个人带到了楼上。他没有问儿子任何问题，但默认他所指的人就是肖娜。辩方辩称，沃克才是强奸和谋杀案的唯一元凶，他撒谎是为了自救。
They claimed he was not out buying coffee on October 27, 1992, but lying in wait for Shauna Howe to leave the church Halloween party. Walker testified to not knowing Shauna personally, but the defense presented two witnesses who argued otherwise. One was a former co-worker at the pizza shop who claimed Walker had met Shauna whilst working there, while another witness testified that Shauna had previously played with Walker's son. James O'Brien's attorney told the court, Ted Walker is evil. He's every parent's, every neighbor's worst nightmare. He's a child molester and he's a liar. He's hoping he gets less time because he's a weasel and he turned other people in. In an attempt to explain why James O'Brien's semen was found on Shauna's clothing and body, the defense claimed his client had sex in the bed at Walker's house earlier that day with a woman named Heather who he picked up in a bar. When Walker took Shauna into bed that night, the semen transferred onto her clothing, which was then stuffed into her mouth to silence her. The defense could offer no explanation as to why, if this was the case, there was no DNA found on Shauna from Ted Walker or the mysterious Heather, who they were unable to produce for trial.
他们辩称，在1992年10月27日，他并不是出去买咖啡，而是在伺机等待肖娜·豪尔离开教堂的万圣节派对。沃克作证称自己不认识肖娜，但辩方出示了两名证人来反驳这一说法。其中一人是披萨店的前同事，声称沃克在那里工作时曾见过肖娜，另一名证人则作证说肖娜以前曾和沃克的儿子一起玩耍。詹姆斯·奥布莱恩的律师在法庭上说：‘特德·沃克是个恶魔。他是每个父母、每个邻居最可怕的噩梦。他是个虐童者，也是个骗子。他希望少判几年，因为他是个卑鄙小人，把别人给供出来了。’为了解释为什么在肖娜的衣服和身体上会发现詹姆斯·奥布莱恩的精液，辩方声称他的当事人当天早些时候在沃克家的床上和一个在酒吧结识的叫希瑟的女人发生过性关系。当沃克那天晚上把肖娜抱到床上时，精液转移到了她的衣服上，衣服随后被塞进她嘴里以让她闭嘴。辩方无法解释，如果情况确实如此，为什么肖娜身上没有检测到来自特德·沃克或那个神秘的希瑟（辩方无法出庭作证）的DNA。
Timothy O'Brien's lawyer James Goodwin claimed there was not a single piece of credible evidence to link his client to the crime, arguing he was only on trial because of his brother's DNA and the O'Brien's history of committing crimes together. Most of the evidence against Timothy O'Brien came from his alleged jailhouse confession to a fellow inmate in 2001. However, the credibility of the inmate making these assertions was thrown into doubt when it was established he had fabricated some of the details of Timothy's alleged confession. During the trial, members of the jury were escorted to Oil City where they walked the route that Shauna had taken on the night of her abduction and visited the abandoned railway bridge in Coulter's Hole where her body was found. The fact that the brothers were currently serving jail time for unrelated charges was withheld from the jury in case it prejudiced their opinion of them. Each day after the jurors left the courtroom, Timothy and James O'Brien were shackled and let out of the building. After two weeks of court proceedings and nearly 17 hours of deliberations, the jury reached its verdict. Just one day before the 13th anniversary of Shauna's abduction, her family sat quietly in the courtroom, holding each other's hands as they nervously awaited the decision. Across the room, the two accused casually chatted and chuckled with one another as they awaited their fate.
蒂莫西·奥布莱恩的律师詹姆斯·古德温声称，没有哪怕一条具有可信度的证据将他的当事人与这起犯罪联系起来，并辩称他受审仅仅是因为他兄弟的DNA以及奥布莱恩兄弟共同犯罪的历史。针对蒂莫西·奥布莱恩的大部分证据都来自他在2001年向同狱犯人做出的所谓狱中供述。然而，当证实该犯人捏造了蒂莫西所谓供述的一些细节后，这名作证犯人的可信度受到了质疑。在审判期间，陪审团成员被护送至油城，他们沿着肖娜在遭绑架当晚走过的路线行走，并参观了库尔特斯霍尔（Coulter's Hole）发现她尸体的废弃铁路桥。兄弟俩目前因不相关罪名在监狱服刑的事实被对陪审团隐瞒，以防这会带上有色眼镜影响他们的意见。每天陪审团离开法庭后，蒂莫西和詹姆斯·奥布莱恩都会被戴上手铐带离大楼。经过两周的法庭程序和近17小时的审议，陪审团作出了裁决。就在肖娜遭绑架13周年前夕，她的家人静静地坐在法庭里，紧紧握着彼此的手，紧张地等待着判决。房间的另一头，两名被告在等待命运审判的同时漫不经心地互相闲聊、嬉笑。
Both Timothy and James O'Brien were found guilty of second degree murder, third degree murder, involuntary deviate sexual intercourse, kidnapping, and criminal conspiracy to commit kidnapping. They were found not guilty of first degree murder and rape. The brothers showed no emotion with James passively chewing gum as the verdict was delivered. Shauna's family celebrated quietly, hugging one another with tears in their eyes. When it came time for Judge Oliver Lobar to hand down prison sentences, he made certain the O'Brien brothers would never be released, telling the pair. The world was a better place because of Shauna, and the world will be a much better place without you walking free ever again. When reading the sentencing remarks, the judge said, When reading the sentencing remarks, the judge said,
蒂莫西和詹姆斯·奥布莱恩均被判二级谋杀、三级谋杀、非自愿异性恋性交、绑架以及串谋绑架罪名成立。他们被判一级谋杀和强奸罪名不成立。兄弟俩表现得毫无情绪，詹姆斯在宣读判决时甚至还在心不在焉地嚼着口香糖。肖娜的家人静静地庆祝，眼里含着泪水互相拥抱。当轮到法官奥利弗·罗巴尔（Oliver Lobar）宣判刑期时，他确保了奥布莱恩兄弟将永远无法获释，他对两人说：‘因为肖娜，这个世界变得更美好了；而没有你们两个重获自由，这个世界将会变得好得多。’法官在宣读量刑评语时表示：‘法官在宣读量刑评语时表示：’
The conduct of the defendants far exceeded the means necessary to commit these crimes. The victim did not have to be killed, and this was done in an attempt to cover up the terrible things that had been done to her and to prevent her from identifying her captors. The throwing of this young victim from a railroad trestle inflicted upon this young child a terror and horror that went far beyond the typical violation of involuntary deviate sexual intercourse and criminal conspiracy to commit kidnapping. What extreme cruelty it was to throw a child who was alive off the trestle onto the rocks below. What a horrific way for anyone to die, especially a young child. The evidence in the form of photographic autopsy evidence clearly shows a cruelty that is not necessarily a typical part of these crimes. These crimes had a devastating effect upon the victim's family, the citizens of oil city, and all the members of our surrounding communities. Following Shauna's abduction and the finding of her battered and broken body, fear gripped our community.
被告的行为远超实施这些罪行所需的手段。受害者本不必被杀害，这样做是为了掩盖对她犯下的可怕罪行，并防止她指认出绑架她的人。将这个年轻的受害者从铁路栈桥上扔下去，给这个年幼的孩子施加了超越了非自愿异性恋性交和串谋绑架罪典型侵害的恐怖与惊骇。把一个活生生的孩子从栈桥扔到下面的岩石上，这是何等极端的残酷。对于任何人来说，这都是一种极其可怕的死法，更不用说一个年幼的孩子了。尸检照片证据形式的证据清楚地显示了一种不一定是这些罪行典型部分的残酷行为。这些罪行对受害者的家庭、油城的市民以及我们周边社区的所有成员都造成了毁灭性的打击。在肖娜被绑架以及发现她饱受摧残、支离破碎的尸体之后，恐惧笼罩了我们的社区。
Citizens changed the way they went about their day to day activities. Youth activities were restricted and even eliminated, and this effect continued for more than a decade. We find that both defendants have demonstrated absolutely no remorse for their despicable conduct. We find that both defendants are extremely dangerous predators, and we need to protect society from both of them as long as possible. Therefore, we have imposed consecutive sentences in this case in the event there would be some change in the law which would make them eligible for parole on the charge of second degree murder. We certainly believe that any lesser sentence would depreciate the seriousness of these crimes and their disastrous effects. As news spread that the verdicts had been delivered, Shauna's supporters drove past the courthouse beeping their horns and shouting derisive remarks about the defendants. The next day, the third accused, Ted Walker, filed a motion to withdraw his plea to third degree murder and kidnapping.
市民们改变了他们日常生活的方式。青少年活动受到限制甚至被取消，这种影响持续了十多年之久。我们发现，两名被告对他们卑劣的行为表现得毫无悔意。我们发现，两名被告都是极度危险的掠夺者，我们需要尽可能长久地将社会保护起来，免受他们两人的危害。因此，我们在这起案件中判处了连续执行的刑期，以防法律发生某些变化，从而使他们在二级谋杀罪名上获得假释资格。我们坚信，任何较轻的刑期都会贬低这些罪行及其灾难性后果的严重性。随着裁决下达的消息传开，肖娜的支持者们开车驶过法院，按响喇叭，并对被告喊出讥讽的言论。第二天，第三名被告特德·沃克提交了一项动议，要求撤回他对三级谋杀和绑架罪的认罪。
He believed the jury might find him not guilty due to the prosecution's argument during the O'Brien trial that he had not participated in Shauna's sexual assault or murder. His request to withdraw was denied, and for his involvement in the crime, he was sentenced to a maximum of 20 to 40 years in prison. Shauna's mother Lucy expressed relief at the result, saying, I needed this to be solved. These people will never hurt anyone again. They took a little girl's life. On October 27, 2005, 13 years after Shauna Howe embarked on her last walk home, the final candlelight vigil in her honor took place. A representative for the family said, This will be more of a celebration. We're just going to remember Shauna. It'll be a glorious day. Crowds of supporters walked alongside the 11 year old's family, holding posters with the words justice for Shauna,
他认为，由于检方在奥布莱恩案审判期间的辩论中指出他并未参与肖娜的性侵或谋杀，陪审团可能会裁定他无罪。他撤诉的请求被驳回，因其在该罪行中的参与，他被判处最高20至40年的监禁。肖娜的母亲露西对这一结果表示宽慰，她说：‘我需要这个案子水落石出。这些人再也不会伤害任何人了。他们夺走了一个小女孩的生命。’2005年10月27日，在肖娜·豪尔踏上她最后回家之路的13年后，最后一次为她举办的烛光守夜活动举行了。家属代表说：‘这将更像是一场庆祝活动。我们只是要记住肖娜。这将是光荣的一天。’大批支持者与这位11岁女孩的家人并肩游行，手里拿着写有‘为肖娜伸张正义’字样的海报，
as they traced the route from the First Free Methodist Church to the Reed and West First Street intersection. Those who were unable to attend but still wanted to honor Shauna's memory were asked to turn their porch lights on at the time of the procession. Three years later, Oil City took the final step in healing from the devastating crime that had defined their town. In August 2008, a local schoolgirl named Elizabeth stood before the Oil City Council at the Monthly Council meeting, holding a petition containing 175 of her classmate's signatures. Elizabeth lived on the same street that Shauna once did, but wasn't alive to experience the terror that gripped her hometown after the young girl's death. On behalf of the town's children, the 10 year old requested that the nightly Halloween celebrations that had been outlawed since Shauna Howe's murder be reinstated. Elizabeth presented the city with her list of reasons why the council should restore after dark trickle-treating, pointing out that Halloween decorations are best appreciated at night, and that many people aren't home during the day to hand out candy. Teachers from Shauna's former school, 7th Street School, encouraged Elizabeth and supported her petition.
他们沿着从第一自由卫理公会教堂到里德街和西一街交叉口的路线前行。那些无法出席但仍想纪念肖娜的人被要求在游行举行时打开门廊灯。三年后，油城迈出了治愈这座小镇所经历的毁灭性犯罪阴影的最后一步。2008年8月，一个名叫伊丽莎白（Elizabeth）的当地女学生在每月的市议会会议上站在油城议会面前，手里拿着一份收集了175名同班同学签名的请愿书。伊丽莎白和肖娜曾经住在同一条街上，但在年轻女孩遇害后，她并没有经历过那场笼罩她家乡的恐怖。代表全镇的孩子们，这个10岁的女孩请求恢复自肖娜·豪尔谋杀案以来被取缔的万圣节夜间庆祝活动，伊丽莎白向市议会陈述了恢复天黑后不给糖就捣蛋活动的种种理由，指出万圣节装饰在夜间欣赏效果最佳，而且许多人白天不在家分发糖果。肖娜曾就读的学校——第七街学校的老师们也鼓励伊丽莎白并支持她的请愿。
The council vote was unanimous. By October 31, 2008, the ban on night-time trickle-treating was lifted, and for the first time in 16 years, Oil City's children took to the streets in costume as spooky celebrations were in full swing, albeit with twice the number of police on duty. Oil City police chief Robert Wenner, who was a patrolman at the time of Shauna's murder, said, No one will forget Shauna, and nor should they. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
市议会的投票结果全票通过。到2008年10月31日，夜间不给糖就捣蛋的禁令被解除，在16年来的头一次，油城的孩子们穿上戏服走上街头，阴森的庆祝活动全面展开，尽管当时执勤的警察人数增加了一倍。油城警察局长罗伯特·温纳（Robert Wenner）在肖娜遇害时是一名巡警，他说：‘没有人会忘记肖娜，他们也不应该忘记。’这个剧集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。